[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 62 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I am Franciscan polling I'm here with my
colleague mark modèle hey Mark how are
you doing I'm good thanks Francesca are
you doing today doing great very very
very happy about having the opportunity
to interview someone about cloud spanner
yeah and not only someone but the
product manager of glad spanner yeah
it's gonna be really really cool super
looking forward to that because spanner
is really interesting in a minute we
will be joined by deepti shrivastava
she's the project manager for cloud
spanner and after that we will have a
question of the week that comes directly
from the amazing Jesse frisell I know
which is related to how to run mail
servers on the cloud specifically on
Google cloud platform obviously
obviously yeah but before that we have
we have our cool things of the week as
usual yeah so the first cool thing of
the week comes from our boss really Greg
Wilson the fantastic Greg's ramblings on
Twitter which is a picture of each
google cloud product described in four
words or less yeah when he says picture
I think it means screenshot this is not
a guess picture of the products but it
is basically like what is cloud data
proc well it's managed spark and Hadoop
okay yeah like it's always what is cloud
logging it is centralized logging yeah
that is but some of them are very very
useful like some of them are all feels
like speech API it converts speech to
text cool but when you're reading
something that you might not know that
much what it is like for instance I
don't know like what is let me see a
cloud shell shell is kind of a weird
thing to say it's actually a
browser-based terminal c li yeah or a
cloud big table is HBase compatible no
sequel yeah I don't know I really get I
think is a very useful teach it to you
have around especially if you're trying
to explain to people what Google cloud
has this is a very good thing to share
easily we have the screenshot but also
we have a spreadsheet on google docs
that you can go and copy paste and
modify as you wish awesome for the other
cool thing of the wake i thought was a
particularly nice one on the big
side we currently are having a challenge
with a google cloud and youtube to
protect youtube video tags for a chance
to win up to 30 k nice so in partnership
with YouTube Google research and cargo
Google cloud platform basically have set
up this thing where you have a public
data set with i believe it's about eight
million video tags so close seven
million video urls which is around
450,000 hours of video and tweet that
two billion will be audio visual
features that's a big number that's a
big number yeah that is a big number yes
okay why they call it am ok interesting
but that's fine um oh yeah interesting
yeah good 8m because they have seven
million YouTube videos yes interesting
yeah whatever so basically using cloud
machine learning tensorflow or basically
any of your favorite machine learning
frameworks the challenge is to develop
classification algorithms so you can
basically accurately assign labels to
the videos that are playing so you can
use those those videos that are
available in that data set to build your
own classification systems and hopefully
win like 30k nice i don't think i will
have time to get in to do it but you can
use yeah google cloud machine learning
and tensorflow or whatever you feel like
using yeah if you have any any cool
software that that you think could do
better than everything else go go for it
yeah and it's worth noting to read so
specifically will link to the page but
you can sign up for basically a google
cloud platform trial account if you want
to try it out and there is a process
there if you end up using more than
three hundred dollars that you get with
free trial and you're working on this
and you want some more credits there's a
form there that you can apply for as
well to get some extra credits so you
can keep working on what you're working
on call so i guess it's time to go chat
with dipti about blood splatter let's go
do that so i'm very very happy to
welcome today to the podcast to the
cloud spanner product manager deepti
srivastava how are you doing very good
thank you that was a good pronunciation
thank you having practicing so we're
very excited about having you today
especially because you know it's like
class banner was launched couple days
ago ready
and there's so many people that have so
many questions about cloud spanner and
the difference between klutz planner and
spanner what does it do and the cap
theorem with the DVD we break it all
that stuff but before we get into all of
those details why don't you tell us a
little bit about yourself and what you
do at Google sure um so my name is
dipesh roster if you did a great job
with that by the way [ __ ] I am the
product manager for cloud spanner I've
been at Google for a little over four
years and I was actually responsible for
launching the internal spanner service
as well so I have a long history with
spanner that I'm very excited to share
today nice excellent alright so let's
get stuck in so from a high level what
is clouds better so clouds banner which
we launched this week very exciting for
all of us in in spanner and as well as
in the in general Google Cloud we're
excited to have that product is a fully
managed horizontally scalable relational
database service that can have acid
transactions in sequel semantics without
giving a performance and high
availability so that was a lot of words
let's unpack okay basically what spanner
or clouds banner does is it gives you
the best of both worlds so it gives you
the best of traditional relational
databases as well as traditional
non-relational or no sequel databases so
what that means is we have schemas ddl
statements strong typing sequel query
and and much more in that category but
we also have horizontal charting that
can span multiple availability zones and
multiple regions across the globe and we
can do all of this without compromising
on performance or high availability and
to top it all we've offered this as a
fully managed service so you don't have
to worry about sort of managing this
database yourself it's completely
managed on the on the cloud platform
with our as a reteam and the entire you
know infrastructure the google runs yeah
kind of like what we did with big table
but for relational cracks nice so you
mentioned that you were responsible for
the internal launch of spanner and also
for cloud spanner which is the external
service could you talk
a bit about differences between those
two a little bit of the history of how
this happen sure um so let me tackle the
first thing first so cloud spanner is
basically the internal span of service
that we've been running from multiple
years which has been developed for even
more years and it's just a repackaging
off that service as a Google cloud
platform service so we basically
integrated with the cloud platform
things such as billing and you know
providing the API is through the various
rest and grp see methodologies etc right
so it's just is the same serve as the
underlying infrastructure is exactly the
same and it's run by the same as a
routine or managed by the same as a
routine that manages the internal
service as well there is really no
difference except for the way you access
the service so it really sounds like
another example of where we've taken
stuff that we've built inside Google and
manage inside Google and right inside
Google and had power all that stuff
inside Google inter said hey customers
here's the thing that you might want to
use as well you know so I've asked been
asked this question from customers as
well cuz they're like are you just
throwing what you had internally
externally and just expecting people to
handle like whatever you throw out there
and that's not what we've done we've
actually spent a lot of time both
evaluating whether spanner would be in a
useful external service to a club
customers and then we spent a year or so
in our early access program where we had
customers sort of working with us as
partners evaluating sort of what the API
should look like how you know how we
should offer it what are the features
that need to be there so you know what
do our enterprise customers actually
need of because spanner itself has a
huge surface area or features and API
you know we didn't make it complicated
and confusing for the customers and
there was actually a demand for
something like spanner hmm and then you
know we developed that as the clouds
banner service in it and launched it
cool so going back to the to the
question about the history mhm so when I
joined Google I was a software engineer
and I was working in AdWords back in and
everything was my sequel everywhere like
and it was
fun and then everyone was that side to
migrating to spanner yep and and for me
was pretty crazy because like every at
the same time that we were migrating to
splatter everybody else was migrating to
non-relational databases why did we
create rather moving to spanner or the
question would be why would you use
spanner instead of like big tables after
that that's an easy answer right like
big table is not a relational database
right it's a wide column store or you
know key value store at the end at the
bottom of it writes in the sequel system
and spanner is a essentially traditional
relational system with with scale but to
go back to the history so basically
about two thousand seven ish or so you
know Google was facing the issues that
current enterprise or just current
companies face today which is they
really need relational transactional
semantics because that makes development
of applications easier and it makes
reasoning about things that you really
care about like you know your bank
accounts and things like that are much
easier because you have transactions but
with the explosion of data there is so
much data and you want so many more
insights from that data that a
traditional single box sort of you know
a vertical solution for the database
doesn't actually work right so you you
need to go to no sequel or something
that scaled out and that becomes really
problematic because if you choose them
no sequel solution then you have to
build all the transactional semantics
and and such in the application you
don't get sequel you get something
sequel like which you have to train your
developers using this exact esoteric
thing etc etc so we were facing the same
challenge and so a group of you know
engineers like Jeff Dean and Sanchez
nandra fikes and a whole bunch of other
people kind of got together and started
to look at what can we do about this and
that's what kind of spanner came from
right so we wanted to have a
transactional system with relational
semantics and strong schemas and types
which also provided horizontal
scalability you know with global
presence and
and those qualities because that's what
you know Google applications themselves
need right like Adwords yeah and then
many more since then and so that's kind
of the history of spanner and as we
developed it we realized that actually
sequel is really useful as a way to sort
of access this data and it's it's very
prevalent and it makes the lives of the
peloton developers much easier to use
like standard sequel and so we built in
sort of a sequel engine into spanner
which is what we offer now today which
uses what we call Stan article which is
an c 2011 compliant with extensions so
does that include things like joins and
stuff like that like fancy cool things
that you can do with the sequel yes so
it's it's a query only so select only
sort of sequel into focus but yes it has
joins it has you can join across many
tables any number of tables in your
database you can do inner joins outer
joins that you can do indexes we have
strong secondary indexes like you have
with any other database we have those
indexes are called local or global
depending on whether use interleaving or
not which again you can look these
things up on the underlight so I watch a
talk not long ago about someone from
someone that used to work at Google I
don't know maybe you have no you know
her because she used to work in that
team Neha narula I don't never heard
about her but she gave a really good
talk okay she gave a really good talk
about serializable ed and and like the
CAF theorem and stuff like that and she
talks a lot about like what is
consistency and butter all the different
definitions of consistency which is like
what what is what is consistency a gym
in global contestants your consistency
in general what is what what is the
consistency we care about because I've
heard about global consistency
sequential consistency and causal [ __ ]
cultural consistency there's many kind
so utilize it a bit about like what is
this thing that people talk about when
they say consistency related to spanner
in class banner um so first of all
consistencies a whole topic in and of
itself and people get very religious
about it so I want to get there ok good
but to put it simply basically there's
you know their eventual consistent
systems or even
consistent systems which basically means
you know you do an operation and
eventually we can't guarantee when but
eventually all parts of the system will
see that change okay then big table
would be one of those okay data store
data space or does and then there's some
sort of causal consistencies if you are
in the path of something happening right
like so if you observe one thing and
then observe another thing as a causal
relationship between those if there's a
causal relationship between those two
then you will see the outcome if there
isn't then you don't see a change
reflected right and then what what's
spanner has or cloud spanner offers is
strong consistency which again depending
on who you talk to you has dave and
definitions but basically strong
consistency means that if you commit a
change and if the system says it's
committed as in the system accepts it
then all parts of the systems see that
change instantaneously or immediately
right there is not a concept of I saw
some change but you didn't right if you
queried the system from somewhere else
or in a different point in time or
whatever there is no there is no such
thing as eventually getting the
information right you either have the
information or you don't and you have it
together or you don't have like you have
it all together or you don't and this is
kind of what traditional databases offer
a strong consistency that's what acid
transactions actually mean is you know
at audacity consistency isolation and
durability okay there is this consistent
so I want to bring up the magic elephant
in the room the magic of the magical
event so like so we've talked about like
a little bit about cap theorem right so
consistency availability partition
tolerance does that mean like we beat it
Laurel I mean beat the captain yeah do I
beat it as like we defied laws of
physics like what are we doing here yeah
so we certainly did not defy the laws of
physics let's put that out there so so
the question is does span of break a
theorem not really what spanner does is
always chooses consistency over
availability so it always chooses see
over a in face of partitions okay socal
theorem is you know consistency
availability and partitions and how do
you do network partitions to be
Mr Duggan how how does a system handle
that do you see or a in the face of
partitions is the very basic answer and
what we say is that you know spanner
always ops for consistency hence we are
strongly consistent system however
because we can leverage Google's network
networking and network stack which are
highly optimized and because we've built
spanner to be a highly optimal system
when it comes to sort of these things we
can actually get very high availability
and performance as well so spanner
offers up to five nines of availability
and we can be this strongly arms highly
available even in the face of partitions
because of the optimized Google Network
and our own up to my stack so I would
recommend that anybody who's really
interested go look at Eric Brewers paper
on this exact topic it's called spanner
in the cap theorem yeah we link to it
from our website which is claudia google
com / spanner you know it's a full
research paper written by the person who
wrote the cap theorem yeah they have he
has more that paper has more I think he
knows where the got there yeah yeah he
can he can get into that I'm much more
detail awesome alright well so you
mentioned a little bit before you
basically where you said there's a sweet
a sequel query language that you could
use for querying so basically like
listing data and aggregating is from
stepping through it so if I'm a
developer how do I go in and like alter
it or like add data to it what does that
interaction look like so first of all we
have DDL statement so if you want to
change your schema you use general ddl
statements like alter table drop table
add column whatever the interesting
thing about spanner is that all these
schema changes happen online which means
you don't have to bring down your your
database in order for the database to
reconfigure itself where we you know we
lay out the data for these things which
is super cool also if you want to op
alter data you know read right attitude
crowd operations then we actually have
to go through the AP the programmatic
API to do that we don't offer as your
insert update delete in sequel currently
we have plans to provide that later but
currently we don't have that so you have
to use a programmatic API however we've
tried to make that API
as close to sequel as possible so you do
do inserts like the keywords or insert
update on late and you know we have a
mutation API so you can put all these
different statements together into
mutations for reads you can use the read
API if you're familiar with read ap is
from no sequel systems it's so much
easier transition and you can also use
sequel so you can do select you know
star from table nicer you know x equal
to foo or something so the API you were
mentioned not the SQL API but the other
one is that based on gr pc or yeah so we
offer the client libraries in but we
call all silver languages but right now
we're offering them in Java go python
and nodejs and we'll have PHP and Ruby
and and c-sharp later in the year very
very cool and we expect that most
customers because these are the most
popular languages that we know of and
we've seen requests for most customers
should be able to just use these client
libraries instead of having to you know
code against the rest api or the grp
capi we also have a JDBC driver that's a
read-only jdbc driver for those who are
sort of interested in that or more
familiar with those semantics that is
very cool that is very cool nice so
let's talk about if I'm a developer well
I am at the very development but if I
was to create a new project why would it
you spanner like what use cases these
things is like oh yeah you should go
with spanner rather than I don't know
like cloud sequel or maybe datastore a
big table sure that's a very common
question actually and I think once you
look at sort of what you're trying to
accomplish with your with your data
storage system then it becomes much
easier so so as I said spanner is scale
out relational right so if you have a
relational data and you know you really
like my sequel or all your data is in my
sequel and it fits in your my sequel
instance or cloud sequel instance right
then you know you should just use cloud
sequel writing to manage my sequel
service however if you're running out of
sort of the capacity for that my
sequence or cloud sequel instance
because you have way too much data or
way too much work load where that cannot
be handled by one
vertical solution then you know spanner
is a great alternative because you know
either if you're if you're running on
into the seams of your my single box
then you know you have two alternatives
either to go to a shard in my sequel
solution which has a whole you know yeah
set of issues that you have to deal with
managing and maintaining that or you
then have to transition to no sequel
right which you give up all those
goodbye goodbye transactions right yeah
so in that case you don't have to make
that trade oh if you go to spanner
basically in terms of when to use data
store or big table or Spain or sort of
as I said big table is a key value store
it's and you know like your white
columns store it doesn't have sequel or
strongly type schemas or sort of you
know multi-row transactions and and
things like that right but it's great
for a sort of large-scale data analytics
and things like that so you you know you
can totally see that also it's not sort
of synchronously replicated right span
and by default out of the box is
synchronously replicated which means
when you when you write to spanner
you're actually writing to and different
replicas which are in our regional
configuration is three replicas whereas
and they're all a they're not eventually
consistent they are strong like yeah
it's like synchronously replicated
without compromising on performance so
nice and then datastore is a object
store essentially your document store
right it's a cute so again doesn't have
the same relational semantics that
spanner or my sequel have so again if
you don't need relation semantics or if
you just want to it's a great product to
get started on as well like you have low
QPS or low query numbers and you just
want to get started and sort of you know
use a consistent data store like which
is again multi-region and available
highly available then I think datastore
is a great option so now I'm really
curious thank you B query hmm I know a
lot of people who will take data from
maybe datastore or other places budget
[ __ ] into bigquery so that they're able
to do like large-scale querying for
analytics sounds like cloudspinner
we'll handle that workload as well
where's the line get drawn there yeah so
I think this is the oil TP versus olap
conversation because bigquery is
ultimately a data warehousing solution
but in the cloud and with scalability
right so it's really meant for sure
running OLAP sort of style what is all
that sorry I'm yeah so oltp stands for
online transaction processing ok and
OLAP stands for online analytics
analytics processing right I still again
you you know the cool thing about
bigquery is that you can actually import
data from different data sources and
then combine them and then run analytics
on them so do a gregation Zand roll up
some things you can sort of have as much
data as you need or as little data as
you need and you can run a bunch of
queries on this spanner is your
operational database right BIC where is
not an operational database right so
spanner is where you put your production
data that's where you run your mission
critical application and then if you
want to combine that data with other
sources or if you want to run sort of
you know a billing pipeline that's
monthly aggregations or something like
that then you transfer that data into
bigquery you know then you can join it
with others data sources or just run
like lon running operations on it as
well I think we should do definitely an
episode on all the different ways of
storing data because we keep on adding
more and we had one episode 14 I think
it was like storage in the cloud we
should we make that because there's so
many cool things going on so there's so
many other topics that like to cover
like there's like through time and like
super cool stuff we like atomic clogs
and stuff but I don't think we're gonna
have the time to cook to cover all of
those so sure could you share some good
plays like talk or a document where
could I start learning more about these
things I mean depend on what you want to
learn like are you talking about spanner
or about spanner like how they like the
magic sauce behind it yeah so of course
there's a canonical 2012 Oh SDI research
paper that you can see on research on
google com that's a great starting place
to like you know understand where
spanner came from in terms of spanner
right now and clouds man of the service
pacifica lee i would recommend going to
our technical documentation page which
is cloudy a.m. /span or / docs we
actually have a white paper section
there where we kind of basically talk
about the technical details of some
parts of our system that are we've
learned are very exciting to a lot of
our developers and we kind of try to
open the hood a little bit so that you
know people can understand well how do
reads and writes work and how do queries
work and how do you optimize queries and
how do you have efficient schemas things
like that so I would recommend that
white paper section as well and either
by any chance any sessions going on at
plowed next is anyone go at a club next
going to talk about spanner and goodness
see me they are actually we have at
least two sessions on an odd spanner
there is a spanner 101 or sorry cloud
spanner 101 and cloud spanner 201 so I
would recommend people who are going to
to next to attend those if they want to
learn more about spanner awesome um yeah
I think as the name suggests one of them
is more of a broad overview and the
second ones yeah and they were going to
be recorded so if you can not attend
don't worry we've got you covered we
really is that later on I don't know
exactly the dates but soon yeah so I'm
also wondering like is anyone do you
know publicly about anyone who's using
cloud spanner now in the wild what are
they doing with it yeah so actually as I
said earlier we ran an early access
program that generate a tremendous
interest and many companies signed up
for that to try it out and to give us
feedback which is where we you know took
the time to then generate or create the
cloud spanner product two of them are
actually mentioned in our blog post that
we had for the clouds banner release and
on our sort of product page which is
cloud Doug load accomplice banner which
is quizlet and JD a quizlet actually did
a deep dive sort of analysis because
they have a shard in my sequel solution
all right and yeah they had all sorts of
problems with it so you know they were
looking for the next next generation
thing that they could go to and
hopefully forget about all the headaches
that they had with the shuttered
solution so they have a pretty in-depth
technical blog that they wrote that is
again linked from our product page as
well I
we have links to that on the show notes
great yeah so I think those two are
definitely exciting now that we are a
public product we expect more and more
customers to sign up and you know
obviously use this for for their
mission-critical own production
workloads so I'm curious as well what
was was there any big surprises as well
when people said I started playing with
spanner like you like I'd never thought
anyone would do that with it or
something interesting like that because
we'd been running spanner service
internally we kind of come across most
of the kind of questions I will say the
level to which people were excited about
sequel so there I said a little bit you
know internally at Google as you were
saying people are very excited about
sort of the no sequel oh yeah it is api
and so or used to be anyway um now we
have over 2,000 customers using spanner
so nice um but it's it's interesting
when we you know when we did these hack
we did hack days with some of our
customers which was very exciting to us
and everybody that like looked at sequel
they were like no you can't do this can
you and then real I guess we can yeah so
so we decide your legs bar across the
world pretty much and we capped the
sequel API and have decided to grow it
as well so nice that's cool so you
mentioned that you were thinking about
growing it what are the kind of things
we might expect from cloud spanner going
on yeah in terms of roadmap I think you
know we obviously are planning to become
generally available you know towards the
middle of this year we have a
multi-region solution coming out right
after and then the general idea what
spanner is too or the general plan is to
integrate with other gcp services such
as data flow bit query pub/sub you know
all those kinds of things so that you
know gcp or can be your one-stop data
shop where you can you know use spanner
for your production workload but also
have you know messages using pub/sub
that can automatically happen and you
can automatically transition your data
into bigquery for those federated
queries and things like that so I think
we have an interesting year plus ahead
so where is spanner specifically
targeted like size of company pricing
where does
position itself in terms of the audience
that would be participating and using it
so spanners actually doesn't really
matter like which size company you are
really it's about what features do look
for and does banner have them or not so
it could be for SMEs or it could be for
enterprises I can tell you that from a
feature point of view we definitely have
you know we're enterprise-ready with the
features like we have I am which is
identity and access management in the
beta product already we have audit
logging we have encryption at rest by
default you know we have a JDBC driver
as I said we had sequel which is an c
2011 compliant and we have client
libraries so you know we're definitely
enterprise-ready but i think any size
company can sort of take advantage of
these features without extra effort so
it kind of comes free yeah as part of
the system out of the box and so you
know if you're even if your startup or a
small company but you you know your data
is your prized possession it's your
business you know intelligence or your
business the strong point then you know
you can start with spanner and then you
don't have to worry about ever having to
deal with scale or managing that
database or you know provisioning for
disaster recovery by replicating it into
multiple availability zones all those
things come sort of built-in and by
default right so it has a lot more than
just scalable you know relational
database to offer right and decided to
tell my availability it has high
performance it can grow and grow as your
data grows and you have to worry about
it you focus on your business and
growing it and we take care of the rest
so if I'm like a four-person team but I
want to build an X Pokemon go I should
be looking towards something like this
rather than just putting my sequel in my
own box somewhere I mean I would say if
you're looking at putting your my sequel
on your own box sure right but then you
don't get all the availability and sort
of management yeah yeah four out of the
box but yeah I know I'm gonna get this
huge pipe line of traffic then I need to
build accordingly yeah I would say the
other aspect here which I've heard a lot
about over the last couple of days since
we've launched his pricing mhm you know
there's been a lot of sort of
consternation on you know whether it's
really priced for smaller companies and
I would say you know we put a lot of
thought and I
sing and I think we are very
competitively priced for the value that
cloud span of offers right if you really
look across the cloud data off data
storage offerings you know with
competitors and stuff I think we are
pretty well priced you know you're
getting a fully managed very high
availability service so imagine you're
not having to get out of bed in the
middle of the night because your
database machine crashed or because you
know it's running out of memories you've
to provision more memory I mean just to
like talk about pricing a little bit
really quickly so when you buy a node
you actually get three replicas of the
node 0 availability zone I was going to
ask you that because that is not the
case for big table for instance right
and big table you need to create a class
with three nodes here one note is enough
one note is enough its list we do
recommend that you create or get three
nodes just for you know production grade
availability and traffic but really you
can buy one note but the point is that
one node gives you three replicas like
three nodes and three different
availability zones all of which are like
right live nodes right they can all
serve data and all they're not just
sitting there as a master-slave kind of
configured down because as I said
earlier spanners synchronously
replicated so there is no it's all sort
of what would be called master master
replication you know you get fully
managed high availability you get sequel
you get sort of the scalability and you
get these regional and multi-region
configurations when they launched so
there's a lot there that you're getting
out of spanner for the price that we're
we're offering it no it's I think it's
definitely worth taking into account
that the fact that you don't need to
take care about like what happens if
your database disappears hi because I
don't know we've heard about stories of
these things happen and the fact that
you know that you don't even need to
care about it at all that is I don't
know if I was running a company I
definitely consider it yeah yeah I mean
it's a trade-off between how much time
do you and your developers and your IT
staff spend managing your database
versus building applications and you
know growing your business right and
what the trade-off look like
nice way to put it cool all right well I
think we are running out of time a
little bit but i'll ask is there
anything we haven't covered or think you
want to plug or promote or announce that
we haven't managed to cover in the in
the half an hour been running so far I
mean there's so much more about that you
can learn about cloud spanner and
spanner there you can you there's
definitely a layered chocolate cake here
and you can sort of keep on layering it
or no appeal yet there is you know a
plethora of information on our on our
sites page and as I mention the white
papers so i would definitely sort of go
there and and check it out and see if
you have you know if you can't find what
you're looking for there and i'll
actually plug something here there is a
very good talk that is from papers we
love which is that talk about the
spanner paper given by an ex-googler
engineer that was working in the team
and it's a pre amazing talk so i'll try
to put that in the Shona too I guess the
good place to start if you're not into
reading papers sure yeah and of course
you know once the gcp next talks happen
they will also be sort of oh yeah i'm
very excited windows so yeah excellent
alright dt thank you so much for joining
us today that was actually it was an
amazing learning experience I learned
more about spender than I knew
previously and I'm very excited about it
glad that I'm glad to be a thank you for
having me and I hope this is useful to
all your listeners yep I'm sure it was
helpful for me and they still hope he
will helpful for them banner for
everyone in the world there you go thank
you so much thanks thanks for having me
thank you so much too deep t for joining
us for a fascinating interview I still
can't decide if spanner is entirely
magical unicorns but it is pretty
amazing in terms of what it does it is
definitely powered by magical unicorns
yeah definitely absolutely absolutely
cool so why don't we go to the question
of the week I sent to us by the amazing
Jesse frizzell yeah so as power of her
basically let's call it integration into
Google she decided to basically move all
her stuff to go clap at forum and she
came up with this little problem she
wanted to run an SMTP server so I mail
server on Google cloud platform and
turns out that it doesn't work so she
asked me
how is this and why not and and I mean
it is it isn't the dogs but I think that
it is something that could be a little
bit surprising so I guess it's worth
discussing yeah so it is definitely
worth noting Google compute engine like
specifically doesn't allow outbound
connections on 25 for 65 and 487
basically because spam and abuse and bad
dance yeah basically there's this thing
called IP reputation so if you're
sending emails the IP where the email is
coming from IP port is actually very
important so we allowed everyone to send
emails from there the IPS would probably
lose their petition quite fast yeah so
it's something we don't really want to
do because it would be bad for our
customers yep so and also because it if
we have very easy way to generate lots
of spam and spam is not good so then we
have these limitations but you can work
around it quite easily you can use some
services that are already available and
we have the commendation on how to use
them so you can use sand grade melgen or
melt it we had that those are the ones
we have fermentation and I think you
used one of them yeah so they all come
with free tears i use singh grid
personally so sing grid comes with a
free trial of up to 12,000 transactional
emails free each month now my blog does
not send out anywhere near that many
emails so it works really really well
even though you send it to all of your
fence all of my fans like like my mom
like a couple of cousins it's a big
family okay cool and then there's also
another option which is you can send
email through google we have an smtp
relay service and basically what you do
is you send it through google apps even
though the email is not gmail so there's
these little service that allows you to
send it from your server but through
google and all the commutation will be
linked from the show notes so if this is
something that you want to do go with
the documentation and of course remember
that even though like you might use
these services you still need to add
firewalls to make sure
the traffic actually goes through as we
discussed in the networking episodes we
had a long time ago you can go find them
and they're very interesting okay cool
all right well that sounds like that
kind of solves that problem what are you
up to France asked what are you getting
up to I know we're leading up to next
which is kind of hectic and crazy but
you got anything else in the cards so by
the time this episode comes out I will
be in india in go freaking india in pune
pune which is how you pronounce it by
the way you know now yeah I know I know
after that I'll stay a couple days in a
Mumbai and then I'll come back for cloud
next and then after that i'll be getting
ready to go to go for cone China and
Shanghai very nice yeah what about you
so when this comes out the week after
that will be game developer conference
oh yeah about that terrifying um because
lots to do there yeah I will be around
if anyone wants to meet up feel free to
ping me directly on twitter at neurotic
i'm definitely going to be floating
around the booth and a variety of events
we're sponsoring and I respond to talk
and all sorts of other fun stuff and
then yeah you and I are heading off to
next yeah and actually you were
mentioning that if someone's coming to
GDC they should let you know if some if
anyone is coming to cloud next yep let
us know we we will have t-shirts we will
have t-shirts will have a booth space
set up we'll be doing recordings again
like we did last year sir and we'd love
to meet you yes oh so come say hi we
always appreciate that well mart thanks
again for such a such an interesting
episode today yeah France s thank you
for joining me once again and thanks to
everyone for listening and I'll see you
all next week got to be on next week
you